[Musique]
mais ce que je suis central, c'est que le
les gens peuvent consommer du cannabis sans
besoin de relier les organisations
criminels et en ce sens, je crois que
n'a pas été pleinement atteint Mais
il y a un pourcentage important de
citoyenneté qui oscille en fonction de cette
Selon les différentes estimations que
Aujourd'hui, vous accédez au cannabis via le
marché réglementé
[Musique]
avoir un contact me parler et le jour ou
le lendemain avec de l'argent et
nous avons acheté
en pharmacie il a un peu de thc et peu
offre pour la demande qu'ils ont habituellement
Il est donc très difficile d'en obtenir beaucoup
fois et se passer d'enregistrement sans supprimer
le temps d'aller à la pharmacie chercher le
drogue
[Musique]
nous avons 45 membres et une liste de
prévu, ce qui est un indicateur que le
la demande n'est pas satisfaite il y a beaucoup plus
les personnes souhaitant accéder au marché légal
ça ne peut toujours pas
[Musique]
nous avons une équipe